phenomenal in the film the whole movies
great at what point did you think that
did you ever feel comfortable in the
role or was were you always you know
what I mean
comfortable yeah yeah there were moments
when I was comfortable because if you
walk out there on stage playing Freddie
Mercury and you're not confident then
you might as well shut down the
production it took a lot of prep and I
think one thing I learned from him was
to be liberated to be free to not feel
like you were compromised by anything
and he gave me a freedom that I could
step out there with and feel like I
could command an audience never quite
like he could but you know I just tried
tried to fill those shoes as best as I
could and honor and justice a human
being that I consider a revolutionary
there's been a lot of people talking
myself included that your performance is
award worthy and what does it mean after
all of the work you put in and to have
everyone who's seeing and just talk
about your performance I mean everyone's
great but they're really singling out
your work and so what does it mean for
like awards talk I you know I could not
have done it without these other actors
I'll tell you that they're just on
another caliber the level
an ensemble here working together raise
my game every day I got I got help from
Brian May and Roger Taylor and
throughout and I have to say that that's
kind of a pretty massive award for me to
have their acceptance to be on a carpet
tonight with them celebrating their
their dear friend and and brother
Freddie Mercury and their band I mean
this is something that you only maybe
get once in a lifetime and I'm getting
to live that if I if I want anything
more than that I'm kind of a punk that
know congrats man for real you're
fantastic
you